he pardoned you how do number one what
were you pardoned for how does that
process work you were
legally you were in trouble you weren't
in jail where you're nothing like that
how what has that work and how does that
phone call happen and then like do you
get to send them a thank you note like
legitimately how does this work well
what happened was my case involved my
case was a college friend of mine
um that I'd known for 20 years decided
to run for the senate in New York her
name is Wendy long and so I told her not
to do it I'm like you're not seasoned in
politics because I'm gonna run so she
ran and and I said okay I'll give you
you're allowed to give ten thousand
dollars in a campaign so I wrote a check
for ten thousand dollars and then my
Obama movie came out uh this is 2012 and
I'm traveling around the country
promoting it I'm doing all these shows
and stuff and Wendy's like you know when
you serve on my finance committee hey
Dinesh you know I know these Indian
doctors you're Indian can you come to a
dinner or may help them give my account
give to my campaign so I felt really bad
so I called up two of my friends and I
said hey guys you like Wendy long give
her 10 grand that's the campaign limit
and I'll reimburse you little did I know
this was a really stupid thing to do
because this follows a foul of the
campaign Finance law but it is almost
never prosecuted or if it's ever
discovered they send you a letter they
give you a warning they maybe give you a
fine so anyway I did something stupid
but they brought the full weight of the
federal government down against me and
as a result of that I was incarcerated
overnight for eight months in a
confinement facility not if you were in
jail yeah I was in jail no no not a not
a normal prison but it's called a
confinement Center but yeah you can't
leave and I'm in a bunk bed it's just
like Danbury right I'm in a bunk bed
with like 60 hardened criminals get out
of here oh yeah so I did I did my eight
months I was done with all that I was
just in what year this was in 2000 uh
13. okay yeah and then um and then I'm
done with that but I'm still on
probation and I still you know like if I
travel like my passport gets dinged I
gotta go to a special room so my point
is I was still quote under scrutiny so
when Trump pardoned me I was doing
community service and I was on probation
but I've actually served my quote
sentence uh but the pardon cleared my
record I mean I can now vote I can own a
gun I mean had you ever been to jail
before in your life prior to that well
you I think you can kind of imagine the
answer is obviously no okay here I mean
no I mean I didn't to me I was like yeah
but I don't know if you know now when he
got out he had an RNC tattoo here at
1776. you want to show it to everybody
I mean even even the criminals knew I
mean they were like what are you doing
here and these conversations to me were
like laugh out loud funny because I'd be
like well you know I was I violated the
campaign Finance
well what
what's a campaign Finance law yeah so I
go well there's a campaign Finance is
that like carjacking I go you know I
gave away too much of my own money
they're like buzz they're like you mean
you didn't take somebody else's money
you're giving money your money I'm like
yeah you're here for that because they
couldn't even believe it so eight months
so back to the Trump part and you he
calls you you get a letter and then like
you get to uh yeah communicate with them
break that down he calls me uh well Ted
Cruz was the one who asked him he goes
you got about in Dinesh and literally
Trump was like hmm done it was like that
wow yeah and then Trump tells uh John
Kelly who was in the chief of staff you
know work it out now I didn't hear
anything for 60 days because they do a
check they run a legal review they do a
few things but then Ted Cruz calls me
and he goes head in there she goes you
got your cell phone on you he goes I got
some interesting news he goes the White
House just called asking for your phone
number so you better keep your cell
phone like on on because they're likely
to call you in the next like 60 minutes
and you can't call them back
so sure enough I got the call from Trump
and um and we talked for about 10
minutes on the phone he called you
personally yeah hey Dinesh yeah djt here
you know he uses his phone a lot he's
the guy that uses a smartphone that you
were getting out of jail all right well
he's also very casual he's like I'm here
with John Kelly he's like you know you
know John Kelly know you I'm like no I
mean I know he's the chief of staff but
I don't know General John Kelly General
John Kelly and then we know we talked a
little bit about the situation and he's
like Hey listen I'm gonna sign you a
pardon in the morning and but you know
the tweeting he goes he goes listen
don't tell anybody about it let me tweet
about it first he did say that and so it
was announced to the world buy a tweet
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]